i mean let's not forget like while i was
shooting rizzoli i was going through a
divorce you know there was all kinds of
problems there her my best friend killed
himself that you know it was just and
all it was was just like you know we had
like a couple of just really horrible
people on that set that were always just
like creating problems so it was like i
would go to work and there would just be
so many problems and so many horrible
things to deal with and then i would fly
home and then there would be so many
problems and so many horrible things to
do it just how did you not implode did
you implode oh i did i did and how so
how did you do that because you go to
therapy like i do how did you how did
you navigate how did you what were the
things you noticed about yourself that
you didn't like during that period of
time
oh gosh i i mean i was i had
zero patience i was so depressed
um
you know when
it just it was like it was like this
little box just kept getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and to be honest i
you know i really feel like being like
jane rosoli you know saved my life in a
very profound way
because i could get to work and just
angie would just disappear
and then jane would take over which i
know sounds so wackadoo but that's just
what happened yeah you know
i mean i i think it's a really wonderful
thing when you have a character
i was lucky enough you know at the end
there to be with
you know some very nurturing like when
jan nash came on board that was the most
nurturing most wonderful human being
and i mean our entire like cast and crew
were like you know
beaten children
that were cowering in the corner and
she's just you know i call her
the janda because she's like a big panda
bear and she's just so loving and kind
and sweet and supportive and
collaborative and all of those things
and as we know you know
certain there are a lot of people in our
business that aren't like that well who
you don't have to say who but like what
caused such a dysfunctional family
within the this the filming of brazilian
isles like where the crew would cower on
a corner that's that's dramatic that's
well we have i mean we had a real like
there was a person that was in charge
that was really really dysfunctional
and then i think um it was i think it
was just jealousy
like i think that's just all it boils
down to
which at the end of the day it's you
know it that's their problem you know
and and
when you're people like us and hey and
this isn't this great we're so blessed
we get to pretend for a living and oh my
gosh and my character always wins and
i'm super tough and look at my gun and
yeah yeah yeah and
like how
like where is the problem in that i
don't know i think i don't know i just
think some people just can't
they just can't see what they have and
so they're never there's always this
hole that they're trying to fill and it
never gets full well they always say
that if you're not
happy before you become really
successful or famous
you're never going to be happy
like in terms of what you have to really
work on in other words money and fame
isn't going to make you happy
not at all